welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and it is early in the morning and
i am reacting to what we just saw in the
mandalorian season finale
spoiler warning before i continue
because everything you care about in
star wars could be ruined
if you haven't seen this episode yet go
watch it come back so there's a lot to
react to including the huge twist at the
end of this episode
and a post-credits scene that's right
you got to stick through the credits
because there is a post-credits scene
folks are theories after that tython
episode were right luke skywalker is the
jedi who grogu connected with from that
seeing stone
he looks pretty young gotten some kind
of injections because this looks a
little pre-rendered
but whatever he's got some set green
lightsaber skills and not only is luke
skywalker there so is
r2d2 and we got his post-credit scene
with bib fortuna on tatooine let's just
answer some quick questions what just
happened
so in mando and beau katan's rescue
mission of grogu from moff gideon even
after amanda has defeated mob gideon is
about to hand over the dark saber to
bogatan but she's like
no thanks i have to beat you in battle
in order for me to truly claim it we'll
save that for next season the dark
troopers are closing
in but thank god a solo x-wing is here
and if you know it's just one x-wing
folks you know who's piloting it that's
right
dark robed green lightsaber luke
skywalker
mark hamill is credited here but the
physical performance is by actor max
lloyd
jones kind of looks like him ain't
sebastian stan
what did i tell you and right away he's
like i'm gonna be a real papa kid and he
takes groku away from denjar and
denjarin's like i know this is right and
we're all crying
tommy and i are gonna react to this and
dive into a lot of these questions
in our after show and then r2d2 shows up
and they're gone that's the end of the
episode
until we get to the post-credits scene
and the post-credits scene shows bib
fortuna he is packing on the pounds he's
like halfway to jabba bitfortuna is the
male twilight who was jabba's right-hand
man he is now
on his throne in jabba's palace on
tatooine this is interesting because
it's almost big fortuna's afterlife in
the legend stories
uh but no like weird spider beings that
try to harvest his brain instead his
death comes at the hand of fenix shan
and boba fett
and we find out that that story will be
told in the book of boba fett coming
december 2021
they left that out of disney investor
day so what is the future for each of
these things well i'm gonna go into
what's next for grogu and luke skywalker
in wookie leaks later today stick around
for that but when it comes to
what's next on mandalorian season 3 that
is obviously gonna be the story of the
mandalorian people bo katan
dinjarin as they work together to try to
retake mandalore
and this whole brewing drama between
them over who can truly claim the
darksaber
right now it seems like denjarin doesn't
want it tan does want it but she has to
earn it and we might find some division
between these two where denjarin might
feel like you know what
maybe i do like this blade so that's the
mandalorian meanwhile we have this other
limited series the book of boba fett
that's going to follow boba fett infinix
shand on tatooine that's where we're
probably going to learn the story of how
boba fett escaped the starlock pit
that's coming december 2021
and then we have the ahsoka tano
spin-off that's going to follow ahsoka's
hunt for thrawn
that is probably going to team her up
with sabine wren dave veloni said that
that rebels epilogue scene might
actually take place
after the mandalorian series so that
whole search for ezra bridger with
sabine wren
and while they're all chasing after
grand admiral thrawn that's gonna be in
the ahsoka show but yeah we are left
with this question
of luke skywalker and grogu luke
skywalker is right in the middle of his
mystery period in this timeline he has
not yet created his new jedi order
ben solo future kylo ren is born but
he's only four years old or so right now
we're still like six years or so away
before that new jedi order 2.0 starts
getting built and there is some time
here for
luke to get to know grosgu hopefully
though we get to see grogu come back on
the show
though maybe next time we see him it
could be years later maybe we'll look at
a time jump and the next time we meet
all these characters it'll be five maybe
ten years down the line we'll be in the
midst of trying to rebuild mandalorian
culture and the grogu could come back
following
the whole groot trajectory and come back
as a moody teenage grogu
wouldn't that be fun hey let me know
what you thought of this finale don't
spoil it to anyone out there let people
discover this on their own it's such a
cool moment be sure to check out our
great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com
subscribe to the rockstars hit the
notification bell follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars be sure to watch
wikileaks later today
we got so much to talk about and then my
in-depth breakdown of everything you
missed in this episode
is coming on saturday thanks for
watching what an ending
bye
[Music]
you